hey everyone its era threads owner sorry  ENCOM and in this video I'm going to  demonstrate how to get up and sit down  in a chair with a cane to sit down with  a cane the patient is going to back up  to the chair until he fills the chair  with the back of the legs  then the patient will allow the cane to  rest on the side of the chair and place  both hands on the chairs armrest and  place weight on the hands while keeping  the weak leg extended out and been the  strong leg to sit down to sit up with  the cane a patient's going to place the  cane on the strong side and lean forward  in the chair while keeping the weak leg  slightly extended forward then the  patient's going to push down on the  canes hand grip and the chair armrest  and then put weight on the strong leg  and stand in position with the cane  thank you so much for watching and don't  forget to subscribe to our channel for  more videos